Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis... pas tout seul
Je suis avec Alan Jérôme
- Salut !
C'est avant tout quelqu'un qui travaille dans le commerce
Comme il est passé aujourd'hui pour parler d'humour magazine
Je me suis dis: "Je te laisse pas partir sans qu'on fasse une vidéo mon gars !"
Je me suis fais avoir
Commercial, tu aimes les chiffres...
les gros chiffres...
-Les gros chiffres, très gros chiffres
Je vais te demander de penser à un nombre
entre 1 et un million, mais
attention, il y a une contrainte, il va falloir que tu t'en souviennes
il va falloir que tu l'aies en tête en permanence, sinon, je ne pourrais pas faire le truc
donc tu peux inventer ce nombre en fonction de choses que tu connais
tu vois, ton numéro de téléphone, ton numéro de Sécu
Il faut que, à tout moment, tu puisses t'en souvenir dans ta tête.
- D'accord
T'en as un en tête?
-Oui
Tu ne le diras pas?
- Non.
Ok, ça marche. Je vais essayer de trouver le tout dernier chiffre de ton nombre
D'accord ?
- D'accord
Tu me regardes dans les yeux, t'y penses, et quand je vais le dire,
si par exemple c'est 2, quand je dirai "2", tu dis "stop" dans ta tête
- D'accord
Et à priori, c'est pas 2, ok. Donc tu penses, c'est parti
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 0
Ah ça vrillait sur la fin
Attends, je vais prendre de quoi noter, ça et puis un petit marqueur
Quel est le dernier chiffre de ton nombre?
- Un 8
8, c'est bon, ça, c'est bon. Eh, d'accord.
Je vais essayer de trouver le premier, on fait la même méthode,
tu penses et tu dis "stop" quand je le dis. C'est parti
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 0, 1, 2, 3..
*Rires*
Bon, c'est 1?
* Rires *
C'est ça ? (-Hmmhm) C'est ça!
Je pense que tu as pris quelque chose qui a du sens pour toi du coup,
parce que tu veux être sûr de pas l'oublier. Je me trompe?
-Non non non, c'est ça
Vous voyez sa petite crispation? : "oui c'est ça, il commence à m’énerver!"
- On essaye de rester figé pourtant, hein, mais non
Je pense pas que ce soit ta date de naissance, mais je pense que c'est lié
Moi j'ai quelque chose, je l'ai écrit, je vais leur faire voir, tu regardes pas l'écran
- Nan
Et tu nous dis exactement quel nombre tu as en tête
- 18...27...18
18...27...18
- C'est pas possible, j'y crois pas
*Rires*
- Je ne dirai pas quel numéro c'est !
Pour moi, c'est le début de ton numéro de Sécu,
- Hmmm
- 1...82
Et après j'avais un vrai doute parce que t'es pas né sur le mois 71... C'est sûr
- Non c'est pas possible
- C'est pas possible...
Du coup ouais, j'avais un doute...
Et ça c'est quoi en fait?... 718?
ça correspond à quelque chose? Ou pas forcément
-Et pas du tout, pas du tout
ça correspond, si, le dernier chiffre, c'est la date de mon anniversaire
- D'accord
- Mais le 7, c'était au pif
-Ah oui d'accord, OK
- Les 7 boules de cristal
- Ah oui, les 7 nains de jardin, chacun ses références
Donc c'est bon, j'ai trouvé le chiffre qui était caché derrière la tête du commercial !
- INCROYABLE !
- ça peut, peut-être, être une prédiction, ce sera peut être le nombre de pouces en l'air qu'on aura à la fin de cette vidéo
Merci beaucoup mon pote!
- Merci !
- Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air
Vous pouvez aussi commenter, je vous répondrai
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine et rendez vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, ciao!